because we're paranoid that is really
why I wrote the book future dense we
have defined ourselves as the people
that dwells alone we are nature's
victims everyone hates us we always find
ourselves alone when push comes to shove
our friends deserters now that is the
negative self-image of Jewish life that
is developed since the Holocaust since
911 with the isolation of Israeli return
of anti-semitism to Europe and I wrote
this book because I believe that that is
the worst possible self-definition it
will be first of all it isn't true
second of all it's thoroughly miserable
and self-pitying and thirdly it has an
enormous risk of becoming a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you think
you're alone you'll probably find
yourself alone and I see the Jewish
world pursuing these policies and they
are disastrous
that is the residue of anti-semitism
there's an anti Semitism out there but
if you're subjected to it for long
enough it becomes and anti-semitism in
here in its very extreme form
self-hatred but it can take all sorts of
other forms i mentioned in the book that
wonderful remark of the lake Shlomo
Carlebach who went around university
campuses all his life loving everyone
and he used to say III asked people what
are you and I know when somebody says
I'm a Catholic I know that's a Catholic
somebody says I'm a Protestant i know
that's a Protestant somebody says I'm
just a human being I know that's jus now
you know let's move beyond that and so I
have defined in the book a Judaism that
we can share with the world i define
Judaism as the voice of hope in the
conversation of humankind and that's why
I really share my Judaism with a British
public that is ninety nine point five
percent not Jewish I do so broadcasting
to them being a Christian Hindu Sikh
Muslim or secular and we try and share
our wisdom and you know the result is
I'm probably better known by the
non-jewish public then even by the
Jewish public and people like that
there's nothing really threatening about
Judaism because we don't try and convert
anyone so we say look guys this is how
we say things if it makes sense to you
please have it and if it doesn't that's
okay